[Music]
before i go i wanted to
identify one moment in the game the the
nepo game
uh where i felt like um nepo missed a
very serious chance to to put problems
no grishak is not intimidating actually
um
sasha is very very nice like he's
extremely courteous he's a great
commentator
i think we had really good chemistry
and
i'm just not as experienced uh
commentating in russian so one thing i
did was i listened to some previous
broadcasts to get a sense of what
phrases they used because i i haven't
listened to a lot of russian broadcasts
whether in sports or in chess
so you know those transitional phrases
and stuff i'm not as familiar with what
people say
um and it was a little bit stressful but
but and of course i was the lead
commentator because i'm more experienced
whoops
okay so
chess.com this is chess gumroad
all right so this this uh rylopez
opening
is pretty common rook v8 so so carlson
carlson has been has been playing e45
throughout the match
i'm actually going to make a prediction
about magnus's uh next black game i
think he's going to play a sveshnikov i
i don't think he's going to thank you i
don't think he's going to repeat e45 for
some reason i i don't know why but
it seems to me that he's gotten too many
dubious positions
and in in game one he played so he's
played b4 and bishop b7 in this position
now he plays a third move which is rook
b8
yeah we might see a rosalino thank you
zug ask
and they follow a
theoretical line up until around this
point i mean here there's already like
not that many games and somewhere around
this moment magnus makes an inaccuracy
it's not entirely clear where
um but but already like once nepo
once you have the trade on e4 white is
better
and there's a couple of reasons why one
of them is that this knight on c6 is
totally limited by the pawn
white's knight
has a lot of excellent prospects why
it's got a better placed bishop
so these combination of factors give
white an edge
and that edge started to grow magnus
tries to
you know re-maneuver his pieces he gets
his knight to g6
which should be three queen e8 and this
is the critical moment nepo has been
playing very fast up to this moment here
uh grishok suggested a very very
powerful move that was later verified by
the engines
nepo within five minutes plays the move
rook e to d1 which is
which is a a reasonable looking move
right he repositions his rook to a
semi-open file to an open file
but this move actually loses all of the
advantage because it lets magnus
consolidate with bishop e6
and then you have essentially
no more chances until the rest of the
game but the move c4 poses tremendous
problems for black
and it's not an intuitive move at first
right it doesn't look
it doesn't look that good because why
would you block the bishop but the point
is that the pawn is advancing all the
way to c5 it's going to push the bishop
back to e7 and black is going to
experience difficulties untangling the
knight's going to come into f5 this is
just bad for black
so if black plays c5 then the bishop is
loose
knight f5 hits the bishop
and the c5 pawn is weak this other
bishop can come out to a4 by the way
so we couldn't find a inadequate move
for black bishop before rook t1
and if black goes c5 here then the
bishop is totally imprisoned
and white potentially has access to the
d6 square well it was really weird that
nepo played so quickly here he just
didn't sense
uh how
how problematic i think black's position
was or he did and just didn't realize
that subtlety was required here but
anyways he played rookie d1
and after bishop e6 you have this
you know mass liquidation nepo had to
take with a queen
another thing he might have overlooked
from a distance is rook takes a4 allows
rook b2 which is really strong and now
black completely equalizes i mean you
hit the rook
pressure the pawn
um so definitely we can say that nepo
played too quickly in this game and once
you had the end game white is a tiny bit
better
but sasha and i never found anything
concrete magnus played fine here like
maybe not the most accurate but
you know the repositioning of the knight
to e6 was nice
and then once he played f6 um
there was no nothing concrete
no i i disagree i i definitely it's not
as you can't say sort of primitively
that one of them wants a draw they're
playing the position
they're playing the position no he saw
i'm sure he saw c4 i think he
underestimated how powerful
the idea i think they're two things two
things are possible the first is he
didn't fully register how dangerous the
pawn advance to c5 is for black the more
likely theories that he thought let me
improve my position first and then later
i'll be able to go c4 so for example he
might have been thinking
here he can take on d7 and go c4 and
maybe he thought this was just as good
but here there is a very specific line
black plays queen c6 and after c5
wow thank you uh alexander for the raid
of the party of 172. i'm just about to
head on out
um because i'm i won't be able to play
the finals but we're just finishing up a
discussion of
the world championship game which i
commented this morning
i'm not sure if you were streaming in
russian or english but
no it's not even rook b5 but the move
rook after d8 is very strong
and obviously
c takes d6 impossible
and on the next move black is going to
tuck the bishop away on f8 which is a
very safe square
much better than keeping the bishop on
this awkward e7 square
and that's the bottom line i think this
line maybe nepo missed
and once he realized that he was clearly
dejected
um
well white can play c4 here but he
doesn't threaten c5 anymore because now
the bishop on b3 is uh
is x-rayed
so c4 doesn't threaten anything again
black has time to consolidate with queen
c6 rook d a bishop f8 so when you're
thinking about these games you can see
how everything comes down to these very
very fine subtleties you can't make any
grand generalizations it's all
very specific like the reason why nepo
didn't let's say win this game or get
more winning chances
um
surprising
yeah so hopefully this explanation makes
sense and
it is surprising to me that nepo is not
i don't know i feel like there's some
sort of a lack of i don't want to say
passion because in his shoes i would
have probably lost all five games but
there is a certain lack of energy on
both of their parts that's a little bit
disappointing
it's just a sense that you i can't point
to any species well i can point to
specific moves
but it just seems like neither of them
wants to be there somehow i mean grishok
said this
and and it seems like they're you know
neither wants to take any serious risks
and they might still be feeling each
other out and you might see a complete
turnaround in the match
but definitely it's been
on the boring side and no question about
it
no i don't think magnus is concerned i
think
i think
it's important for him to pose problems
in the next game i think the day after
tomorrow he has the white pieces i think
it's going to be important for him
to at least even if the game ends in a
draft to at least get some sort of
advantage out of the opening
because i don't think magnus can keep
giving away the white color and
i feel like with every draw that nepo
makes with black he adds confidence so
the current score is two and a half two
and a half five draws
and i'll be commentating on friday with
uh sasha castano who just rated me in
russian
in um chess camera yeah the second game
was the most interesting
all right guys well i am going to head
on out i will also be doing speed chess
championship tomorrow um with with amman
so
i will be very busy in the next few days
um i might stream later today again i i
probably don't think so i'm just maybe
gonna take some time to rest it's been a
very long day so far
but i'm sorry that i can't stay for the
ak finals i have like three or four
things i have to get done
before the second half of the day so my
apologies for that but i warned you
um
all right i'm going to raid
let's read um i feel like if min is in
the finals i'm going to raid men
do you guys yeah let me see
oh yeah min is definitely and i'm gonna
raid min and
we wish him the best of luck in the
playoffs thank you guys for hanging out
thank you to chess.com for the raid and
alexander for the raid
and uh i'll see you guys tomorrow for
the scc on chess.com
uh in the morning so make sure to tune
in it's gonna be a report versus nihal
super interesting match
thank you guys
and goodbye
[Music]
you